what's the most important tool or the
most important feature in any gym or
training space I think my hot take is
that the answer should be the big open
space in the middle okay so maybe that
was a bit of a trick question but I
genuinely think that any training space
should prioritize space because if you
don't have a large open space there's
just so much that you can't do you can't
do Farmer's walk you can't do sled drag
or push you can't do Sprint drills you
can't do bear crawls or lizard crawls
you can't do battle ropes you can't
practice cartwheels or handstands or
walking on your hands we can agree that
training is about learning to better use
your body right well how can you claim
that you're learning to use your body
when you're spending most of the time
sitting down or standing in place don't
do that enough during the day already
this isn't always a given some gyms try
and cram so much equipment in they don't
leave any open space to do that kind of
thing and more important still make sure
there's open space in your own home I
think it's really important if you
really want to practice using your body
throughout the day bye for now